the og crypto derivatives platform and
the best place to buy your bitcoin
hey guys and welcome back to the lehigh
pen show this show and this episode is
going to be a very special one a little
bit different from what we usually talk
about but very much in line with the
whole concept of freedom and becoming
that sovereign individual so i'm really
excited to kick things off but before we
do this podcast as you know is sponsored
by bitmex so a quick message from bitmex
bitmex is the og crypto derivatives
exchange and now has a spot exchange for
you to buy and sell crypto especially in
a bear market you really need a place
that you can trust and bitmex sets the
standard in reliability performance and
transparency and has proven itself
through multiple market cycles so it
stood the tesla time which is very
important right now bimx is actually
celebrating the start of bitmex spot
with one million dollars in prizes to
give away so to enter all you have to do
is trade the equivalent of 250 u.s
dollars in crypto so you could buy some
bitcoin 250 worth of bitcoin um to enter
buy the dip and you could also um you
can also um enter up to 25 times which
basically means you could win up to 500
thousand dollars in bitcoin so lots of
prizes there to win um and a massive
thank you to bimx again because on this
show we do have the conversations that
nobody else is having really topical
conversations that you're not sort of
allowed to have right now um so a huge
thank you to bit max i'm leaving all of
that information for you in the
description below if you are watching on
youtube um and before i bring on my
guests i do want to ask you all to
subscribe hit the like button so you can
support the channel and you never miss
any of this really valuable content
alright guys let's get this going so
joining me on the show today is the
world traveler investor entrepreneur and
founder of nomad capitalist it is andrew
henderson andrew welcome to the show how
are you i'm
glad to be with you
great to be with you too i've been um
following a lot of your stuff for a
while and i like it a lot um it's very
much in line with um the sorts of ideas
that i that i talk about in terms of
being that sovereign individual you know
preparing for
um
all that's going on in the world um so
let's just kick this off for those who
don't really know much about you can you
just give us a brief background about
who you are and what you do
so
i founded a company called nomadcalculus
which was a result of my traveling all
around the world and noticing uh
inconsistencies noticing arbitrage
opportunities where
investments would be higher yielding in
one country or the people would be nicer
in a different country and so i was
traveling all around the world i noticed
that where i was from the u.s
didn't really like a lot of what was
going on there had been talking since i
was a child with my family about how it
was going to become a
less
positive place for entrepreneurs for
successful people for investors
and
noticed that the culture in their places
was more conducive to entrepreneurship
the people were more welcoming they were
more understanding again interest rates
were higher or whatever
and so uh i
went i thought back to what my father
told me when i was 12 years old go where
you're treated best you don't have to
stay in the same city the same state the
same country
and i got a great permission slip to not
have to stay around and take care of my
family they said listen we're going to
take care of ourselves and you should go
where you're treated best and so i
started noticing how that's not one
place what my father talked about in the
mid 1990s of moving to new zealand
or moving to chile
is not the way that today you need to do
it you don't just move everything down
to new zealand or to chile
you can diversify and so that's what we
talk about we talk about having
passports residence permits you know tax
companies everything in all the
different places around the world so
that you can take advantage of what each
country has to offer that's best
so you you know you spoke about go where
you're treated best but there must have
been something which really sparked you
to want to start a more established
nomad capitalist
well i had started a number of
businesses in the u.s and had done
relatively well
starting that at 19 20 years old
you know back then entrepreneurship it
was not a hashtag on instagram it was
something that was kind of weird and so
socially speaking it was difficult and i
noticed when i traveled to europe i had
much better conversations about
entrepreneurship with people my age
people seem to be a lot more interested
in it um whether from a friend's
perspective whether just you know from a
from a dating perspective it just seemed
to jail more and then later in asia as
well
um
and also i was paying
at the peak like 43 of my income in
taxes
um and that was really inefficient so
i basically said from a social
perspective for me i want to explore the
world from a hey what's happening in
asia this is like the future i want to
be part of that um from all of that
i started asking myself well okay how
does it work with taxes like if you can
work from anywhere if you can make money
anywhere how does that work and i
realized you can you can dramatically
lower if not even eliminate your tax
bill by living somewhere else and so for
me it's like all right i'm going to save
a bunch of money and i'm going to live
in a place or places that's much more
conducive to what i want and i'm going
to have an adventure and so it kind of
uh spiraled from there over the last
dozen or so years now with homes in
six different places and multiple
passports and a very global lifestyle um
you know it's it's been one where i've
created a lot of optionality for myself
just out of interest do you find it
exhausting that nomad that digital nomad
lifestyle
what when i first started well i guess
when i very first started it was i had a
home in the united states and i traveled
more and more and more to where at one
point i was home less than i was away
and i actually brought in like a
roommate because i i bought a house and
i didn't want someone to break into the
house because i was not really there
that often
um
and so you know that travel where you
leave for a month or two months and you
come back and i would you know leave and
come back from europe three days later
go to asia um that wasn't exhausting
because you always have that base then i
did the perpetual nomad where you say
i'm going to travel throughout southeast
asia and every month i'm going to be in
a new country i'm going to meet people
i'm going to meet the ceo of a bank i'm
going to meet
somebody in uh you know entrepreneurship
whatever um that certainly i think does
get old where you're dragging a suitcase
behind you what i developed was the
system of having a base i first found
malaysia as a place to have a base it's
still one of the six bases and so you
know as i'm going to travel for a
conference we're hosting in mexico city
uh in september uh i'm going to pack up
all my clothing in one place go to the
other and then you know come back to
another home so it's much less
exhausting having that infrastructure
where you have places that you can call
home
i think that what people should
understand is my lifestyle doesn't have
to be your lifestyle some people
a lot of our clients they say you know i
make three million dollars a year i want
to be in one place i want the time zone
to be good so if they're working with
americans they're going to live either
in portugal or in ireland or they're
going to live in panama or or something
like that
and so they just live in that one place
it's a tax friendly place and that's
what they do and that saves them on
taxes and they still get to diversify
and everything or you can live my
trifecta four months in three different
places or you can be a little bit
chaotic about it which i've done but you
always have those homes and so i think
that if you build the infrastructure
over time it's a lot less chaotic
so we're gonna get into um what the best
places are you mentioned portugal which
is an interesting one actually um but
before we do what would you say some of
the disadvantages are to only having one
passport
well i think what we've seen in recent
years is um your country entirely
controls what you can do one of the big
things there's been a few big trends in
the last couple of years one of them is
the advent of a wealth tax and related
taxes like unrealized capital gains tax
i'm talking about trends in u.s canada
australia new zealand uk western
countries
uh germany as well um wealth tax is one
of them uh retroactive taxes even but
also oh let's cancel your passport what
was boris johnson talking about if we
don't like uh the way that you you
conducted yourself overseas will you
reserve the right to cancel your
passport the u.s can cancel your
passport for tax debts other countries
talked about that
people from australia couldn't come back
to their own country during the pandemic
in canada it's the one country in the
world it's tightening entry restrictions
and so you may not be able to leave your
country you may not be able to come back
to your country for overseas if you were
stuck overseas everyone thinks like the
vietnam war the helicopters come and
save you if you're an american uh
everyone had to pay for themselves and
you can say that's a good fiscal
strategy but the idea that you're
getting a benefit for being a citizen of
a country is is just not there and so
they can do whatever they want the
united states where i'm from taxes
people no matter where they live merely
because you carry that passport and so
you can dramatically reduce those taxes
it's a little bit harder than a few
years ago but you can get it down to
zero or probably single digits
but you've still got a phone home to the
irs you've still got to tell them where
your bank accounts are and you're still
subject to u.s regulations i have people
who do business
in southeast asia for example and the
way that business is done there doesn't
match up with the way the u.s
uh requires their citizens to conduct
themselves so whether it's taxing you
whether you live there or not whether
it's restricting your freedom of
movement whether it's forcing you to do
anything that takes away from your
freedom um i mean there's so many things
that they can do and you know for me
when i first got the second passport the
first second passport
there's a there's a different feeling i
think you feel it and it's like you know
what now i have options and if this
country over here decides to screw me
hey i can go over here i ultimately gave
up u.s citizenship for a number of
reasons
um i wasn't really paying much in in
taxes legally so the taxes contrary to
the media's narrative wasn't really the
issue but i just felt like they were
making it harder and harder and harder
to be an expat i was a citizen which
should be a benefit but in many cases
countries and politicians are saying no
no it's an obligation
canada now they want citizens a few
politicians are talking about you should
pay taxes for the privilege of being
canadian i thought it was you had the
privilege of having us as part of the
country and it was a service to us who
are part of this tribe no they see it
the other way and so don't you want to
have a backup plan or multiple backup
plans in addition to more places you can
live without asking permission you want
to have backup plans for whatever your
country can do because i think we've
seen it's going to get worse
yeah do you think that um
the need for multiple passports and dual
citizenship is becoming more necessary
as the years go by
well and when how long ago was it like
okay all right fine the u.s uh it's it's
a dump but uh hey
you're from canada right um i mean
you you donate money to some people and
they freeze your bank accounts um by the
way
you know people say oh well singapore is
not perfect andrew banks in singapore
well that's great i don't live in
singapore i don't really care what
happens in singapore as long as my money
is safe and the banks stay in the top 15
safest on earth i'm not there protesting
whatever they're doing in singapore and
so that's the point of the
diversification right i mean when you're
banking for example in the same country
that you are
living and you have a political interest
i mean that's a challenge right so i
want to just live in a place to live i
live in malaysia part of the year and
whatever they want to do it's not my
business
and they treat me well and i get left
alone and everyone's nice and
the tax plan leaves me alone and so uh
it's not my business how they want to
run their country but you know canada
was the place to go australia was a
place new zealand how many wealthy
people i was saying five years ago new
zealand there's much better alternatives
at a lower price point that are just
better and now everyone's kind of coming
to realize that and so i think that you
know what i've talked about is legacy
brand countries
um countries that have this this it's
it's it's coca-cola right um and why is
it cooked like why don't you drink rc
cola why don't you drink the store brand
because coca-cola has been around it's
the legacy brand they advertise
right um
montenegro doesn't really advertise
right malaysia doesn't really advertise
and so you don't think about those
places but yet
the countries that are legacy brands are
getting away with murder in some cases
you mentioned um
how the relationship between the people
and the government um in times of you
know is it
isn't it supposed to be a privilege that
i'm part of your country rather than
it's a privilege to hold that canadian
passport yeah um so
so in what way is that relationship
changing between the citizens and the
state and um why do you think it's
changing uh it was moving towards a more
negative relationship for us
well i think it's largely happening in i
mean like look at the five ice countries
for example look at larger countries i
mean i i had um i was a very
controversial guy the former president
of georgia mikhail sakashvili who
basically put in the constitution that
you have to have a referendum to
increase taxes they slashed taxes from
21 to five or six
they flattened all the rates they
dramatically lowered all the rates and
you cannot raise those taxes by the way
you can live there and pay zero or one
percent as a foreigner but you can't
raise those taxes without everyone
getting together and voting it's not
just the legislature
and and and he seems to think that his
country's a little bit too small because
it's hard to govern and make tough
choices because you walk around to
belize the capital and you see the
people who you had to lay off and you
see their families but because it was a
small country they could turn around at
a dime they fired the entire police
force one day because it was corrupt and
they brought in all new people you're
not going to do that in the u.s how do
you solve the problem in the u.s or even
the uk or even canada number one the
culture is people are so addicted to the
fact that they're living in a legacy
brand country that this is the best how
long does it take to breed that out of
people right where they're just going to
accept whatever comes down because this
is the best even people who complain
about it on our
channel are like
sure but it's still the best thing out
there statistically it's not by any
measure right you have like the 59th
worst crime rate the 72nd or something
like that uh corruption i mean like it's
statistically best u.s canada australia
number one in nothing but everyone
thinks it is they're going to keep
supporting politicians that keep going
further and further down higher taxes
anti-freedom uh on the other hand right
uh they're just such big countries how
are you going to make how is the u.s
going to turn on a dime i mean
like okay i'm going to vote for
republicans
george w bush
took your tax rate from 39 to 35 percent
woohoo right trump took it to 37. if you
make over what 400 grand 450 whatever it
is you're paying 37 plus plus plus
california is raising everyone's worth
right and so uh you could just move
somewhere else and pay zero or pay one
or pay five there's plenty italy and
greece for the love of pete have tax
incentives where you can make as much
money as you want and pay one flat rate
italy and freaking greece
right at least there's a little bit of
acknowledgement and those kind of like
we need to bring in some cash
the u.s isn't ever going to have that
they'll just print more the uk they're
not going to change
so what would you say some of the
multiple um well what are some of the
benefits of having multiple passports
well i think the biggest thing is
optionality right so there's a number
let's talk about how you can get one if
you have a parent grandparent great
grandparent you can get citizenship
potentially where they're from so if
you've got an irish grandparent you can
get irish citizenship okay now you can
live in the uk and they've got a tax
incentive for foreigners you can live in
ireland the tax incentive may be
difficult if you're not a foreigner but
possible you can live anywhere you want
in the european union and obviously the
european union is not as free as many
places but there are places that are
better for certain things bulgaria for
example was
ahead of the game in some things uh even
parts of spain that kind of thing so you
get to choose um if you have that
passport do you want to live there do
you not um but but that's through
dissent you can make an investment i
have a passport in the caribbean um they
don't bother you it's the exact opposite
of the u.s they don't want your taxes
they don't want to know anything about
you okay are you a criminal do you have
a good character we're gonna do a
background check if you're approved
here's your citizenship my point is like
they're not going to be tracking your
banking they're a peaceful small country
no one hates the saint lucians no one
hates the antiguans right no one's going
to get into a tiff with the antiguans
and say you can't get a visa to come to
our country
so i think it allows you to continue to
do business to bank to diversify your
assets have another place to live when
times get tough um have another passport
to travel on open up new places to
travel to have a different you know
identity not that you should lie about
which citizenships you have or claim
that you're
not an american when you are an official
proceeding whatever but
um
it just gives you the option to to pivot
uh and if one day your country
does something where they want to take
more of your money let's say elizabeth
warren gets her way or let's say i just
i just did a video the other day about
um
there's some group that wants to roll
out a simple flat tax wealth tax
on oligarchs in the us eight percent a
year imagine they come after say every
year you have to give us eight percent
of your net worth you can say you know
what here's your passport back i'm going
over here
and who knows how much more difficult it
could be in the future as the us has
tried to force legislation to to push
places like europe to stop letting these
caribbean citizens come
so i mean they don't like competition
the big governments are angry and that's
what this whole global minimum tax that
you're reading about is about how dare
you have a tax rate of nine percent
if you're a small country you want to
encourage business to come and hire your
people and do what's right for your
citizens but the big established
countries the
mafias as it were they don't want
competition they want to snuff that out
they want to make sure you have to keep
paying 37
and so having a passport is in the most
extreme of ways the backup plan that you
can say i'm out
how many passports can you hold at once
i believe different countries have
different rules yeah
so most countries i mean there is a
trend towards dual citizenship we've
seen countries like norway more recently
we've seen like liberia and africa which
you know there are people who can claim
african citizenship by descent but more
countries are opening up germany now the
government they want to tax tax tax but
the one good thing they're talking about
is allowing germans more freedom in in
dual citizenship so that's the trend uh
if you have the ability to hold dual
citizenship generally speaking let's say
you're american you're british you're
australian it basically means when
you're in that country when you're in
the u.s you should be an american you
have to enter in your u.s passport leave
on your u.s passport and so if you get
arrested for example hopefully no one's
getting arrested but if you get arrested
in the united states you can't say hey
i'm also a dominican
let me call the dominica embassy and
then let me help now you're an american
you're here you're an american but what
they say is we don't really care what
you do outside of the country and so you
could hold i mean one guy was was
reputed to have eight
um you know i hold what five and i was
going for a sixth
um so there's really no limit in most
cases as long as none of the countries
has a limit so you'll see some countries
where they restrict dual citizenship
um you'll see others like russia there's
a reporting requirement and i saw
someone got in trouble recently for not
reporting it fast enough um
but if you're if you're allowed to have
dual citizenship that could be
triple quadruple multiple
what's the quickest and easiest way to
get your second passport
well it depends i mean i think
citizenship by descent through ancestry
depending like if you've got a parent
who is born in canada for example a lot
of people don't know this if you're born
in canada born in mexico born in most
countries in the americas you are a
citizen by birth when i give up u.s
citizenship it doesn't say because your
parents are american and says you obtain
citizenship by birth in the united
states
and so uh people don't realize if their
parent was canadian or mexican or argent
you know born there they can apply for
that passport and so canada i think is
relatively fast uh but citizenship by
descent has definitely slowed down might
take a couple of years uh if you just
want the fastest path you would look at
something like citizenship by investment
so you've got five caribbean countries
you've got montenegro where i've got a
home i think it's a very overpriced
program you've got turkey which recently
increased but that's the really the only
program where an investment makes sense
you get to buy real estate not just real
estate on a list as is the case in the
caribbean but you get to buy real estate
anywhere in turkey so if you buy
correctly most people don't if you buy
correctly you can sell that in three
years and probably come out about even
so
for our purposes i would suggest there
are five caribbean countries where the
general option is you make a donation
from a hundred thousand dollars on up or
you go to turkey which has a different
kind of passport obviously it's a big
country it's they have their own beefs
of people um but it's an investment and
so which one do you want if you're if
you're in bitcoin you probably want to
keep as much money in bitcoin as
possible you'd rather spend a hundred
thousand dollars in st lucia dominica
what have you then invest 400 four and a
quarter and wait a couple of years um so
those are probably the six fastest
options uh when you figure out all the
paperwork you've got to collect and
apple style and everything else you're
probably looking at six to seven eight
months
you said that you have five passports
can you tell us which countries those
are i don't talk about it i don't think
people should talk about it i've talked
about some of them i've talked about st
lucia for example the caribbean and i
was very
happy to see that uh you know americans
are 900 up in terms of applications in
st lucia and
maybe one day they'll they'll give me a
flag pin or something but um
i don't talk about i don't think you
should um
i mean i think that
uh you want to
uh you know you want to be diversified
you want to have options i you know i i
specifically so i help my wife
get armenian citizenship through dissent
and she thought it was silly at the time
and i think a lot of people who have
good passports think it's silly to get
such a low quality quote-unquote
passport and yet what she found was it
was so much easier to get residence
permits around the world because she can
get an armenian police report in one day
she can get anything done in one day the
embassies are actually helpful unlike
where she's from and like where i'm from
where everything takes a lot longer so
it's a much better identity and
especially right now where she's from is
from moscow and it's not really the best
way to represent yourself in many places
so um that was a good diversification
for uh for her
um
you know you can talk about that because
that's your identity um but you know i
certainly wouldn't want someone who is
armenian to go and do the turkish
citizenship by investment and by the way
if turkey knew they wouldn't offer it to
you and if armenia knew that you were
turkish they wouldn't let you naturalize
probably so i wouldn't suggest doing
something like that um but certainly you
never know when a conflict could break
out and i wouldn't necessarily want to
be uh on the record not that i believe
in doing things uh
i mean i believe in being very much on
the up and up but um i certainly
wouldn't want to put things out there
needlessly
yeah no i understand that makes a lot of
sense
no yeah i i agree with you i um you said
um low quality passports so
i want to get more information on that
what countries would you regard as low
quality and then which countries would
you say are good passports to hold
i think what i'm using is the is the
kind of the speech that you hear people
saying like they look at the travel
privileges of an armenian
and it's not it's not a lot uh you can
come to asia um you can travel within
kind of central asia you can go to
georgia whatever but like you're not
going to europe without a visa there's a
lot of places you can't go and so what
i've categorized it is there's three
tiers of citizenship there's tra which
is american
british australian where you can pretty
much go everywhere the united states and
australia probably being two of the
hardest
you know okay a minus it's like romania
where you're pretty much going
everywhere as an eu citizen but you need
a visa for the us then you've got tier b
which is most of what i have which is um
you can go to europe right you know you
can go to the schengen area in europe uh
b plus would be could also go to the uk
and ireland which all the caribbean
passports have
right um and then t or c would be you
can go to neither the u.s or europe and
that would be where armenia falls that
would be technically where turkey falls
turkey's pretty strong this is a big
country and there's lots of countries
around the world would love to have
there was 80 million people coming so
turkey or russia
are pretty strong outside of the west
because
all the other countries want them
armenia obviously or a country like that
doesn't really have a lot of negotiating
power to open up all those countries to
travel to and so they're not
particularly wealthy they're not
particularly big and so um you know the
passport isn't as good for travel but
here's the thing if you're british if
you're american why wouldn't you claim
that especially if you have armenian
descent it makes sense
and then you can use it to go to the
countries that they can go to you can
get a residence permit using that
passport potentially more easily than
you could as an american or british
person in some cases it's just it's nice
diversification and you have one big
country one small country so i think it
depends on the mix like i got st lucia
if you came to me and said i want a
passport in the caribbean that would
probably be my last suggestion but for
me it meshed well with the other
passports i had i already had the visa
free travel gaps that st lucia has
covered somewhere else and i thought
that okay for me i want something that's
a bit newer
doesn't really have much of a reputation
you know like doesn't have a bad
reputation hasn't been exposed in some
story and i thought you know that's why
st lucia but if i were recommending it
to someone else that would probably be
last on my list if you were getting one
passport so you have to take things you
know collectively right if if you're
egyptian with of armenian descent
okay take it but that's not really
solving your problems as much as if
you're british and you can add armenian
now
you can go to russia you can go to china
you can go to iran
you've got big country small countries
so that's what i mean it's
diversification it depends what you have
i understand um and so in terms of
you did talk about this earlier but the
passport itself
whose property is that
so
i
know some people without naming names or
making things too obvious um who during
the lockdowns were taken from the
airport and had to go into quarantine
camps and their passports were taken um
so they literally had to go
um so who owns your passport whose
property is it
well i think when you when you're in the
international airport and you're going
through the border i mean they can stop
you um i won't name any names or
countries either but there's certain
places in the americas where
um i mean they they'll put you in a i
mean both the u.s but also some of the
latin countries where they're just like
oh sit over here for a while they take
your passport and they're supposed to
let you call the embassy and they don't
have to so
it's important to go to places where you
are welcomed and where they're just cool
but in terms of who owns your passport
itself yeah the government owns your
passport um they don't have to issue you
one again in the united states and i
encourage everyone to comply with the
tax laws but i got into a scuffle with
california many many many years ago when
i was much less successful over
a thousand bucks
uh imagine if you were 50 times as
successful and it was 50 000 well now
you can be on the irs radar and they can
cancel your passport or refuse to issue
one by communicating with the state
department and so other countries are
doing that in different ways for
different reasons
and so they absolutely own it they don't
have to let you travel now uh you are
supposed to leave the us on a u.s
passport um you know there's no exit
controls in the u.s so some people kind
of have a hard time understanding how
that works but let's say you were a
resident of mexico you know could you go
to mexico and walk over and then have
another passport to travel obviously i
encourage people to play by the rules um
but you know if you can't get a passport
listen pay your taxes uh and if you
don't want to pay them then go where
you're treated best but uh you know i
think the fact that they can they can
stop you from traveling
yeah i think that just blows my mind um
and in terms of you know what you do you
help people um obviously obtain
different passports and things like that
i'm interested to know has your um your
content online your clientele just
everything increased during the last two
years after people saw what has happened
i i forget the percentages but it's been
very very substantial yeah that's crazy
um so this year we're kind of taking the
time we're still up but it's not up like
400 percent anymore partially because
uh from a business point of view we want
to we want to kind of
reposition and make sure that we're we
have the right people in place to to
to drive that because it's just it's
been uh it's been extremely overwhelming
for the last two years it's been
non-stop uh and i'm glad that there's
a little bit of peace right now but no
it's been crazy and what's been
interesting to me is i've been saying
this stuff for a decade and for the
first time you see people from countries
like australia who are like why do i
need a passport
oh you mean your country that violated
international law and would let you into
the country or out of the country i mean
like
the u.n probably not our favorite
organization what is it they said
decades ago everyone should be able to
enter their country and leave their
country that's like citizenship 101 like
you can come and you can go
um and they violated that and so
everyone who was like oh you're living
now you live in malaysia yeah okay well
i left malay nobody stopped me from
leaving malaysia uh now i mean there
were a few countries where if you were a
citizen of the country um
they restricted citizens well that's the
kind of country you wouldn't be a
citizen of you'd be a resident that's
the country to be where citizenship
would be difficult so we're finally
seeing
all these western countries not just for
tax reasons but now for personal freedom
reasons seeing that the bloom is off the
roads and
their place is just
it's just an expensive version of
everything else it's like
uh you know i need some shoes i'm going
to prada listen if you like prada shoes
buy them and pay 20 times the price but
you are paying 20 times the price
uh for
not that much better shoes i happen to
like the shoes so i buy them but like i
get it like you could buy leather shoes
somewhere else and so people are
realizing i'm paying all this money
right what was it in germany recently um
landlords are turning off air
conditioning because this government you
pay half your money and taxes to
couldn't figure out that the west has
been at odds with the country that
provides a lot of their energy for how
long now and they never had a backup
plan so that in the middle of the summer
landlords are conserving by turning off
people's electricity and you've been
paying them all these years to figure it
out for you don't hey just relax and
we'll take care of it you paid the bill
and they don't deliver the service
yeah it's absolutely incredible and i
think it was trump actually who
predicted that that was going to happen
and everybody uh sort of laughed at him
um for saying that um but
the last few years have been so
enlightening and fascinating for a lot
of people i know people often say they
were red pilled over the last two years
you know really like realizing and the
extent to which the government will go
um so which countries would you say have
but have um
become more free has anything sort of
changed your mind and which countries
are more favorable than others
well there's two areas that we focus on
so our area is on holistic planning so
it's finances freedom and lifestyle and
i think that especially coming from a
u.s background you have to match it up
it's not just a matter of leaving the
u.s and hoping it all works you've got
to figure out your residence your
citizenship your tax plan your personal
your corporate everything at once
um
so there's the tax part and i like the
fact that countries like malaysia and
uruguay came out and said we're not
going to raise taxes
um i like the fact that you're seeing
again some of these countries in europe
that are that are doubling down on their
tax incentives including the italy's the
greece the islands uh etc um for
personal freedom we've seen latin
america obviously mexico has been a
standout they were wide open through all
of it now they are becoming um i mean
it's not just you you can't live in
mexico as a tourist anymore good thing
is residence is pretty affordable to get
you don't need to invest you need to
have money but the days of the 180 day
tourist visa no questions ask leave come
back a day later that's over by all
means
in mexico but mexico is free um
i mean panama was difficult at first i
think i was in colombia for a good chunk
of 2021 and i would say that was pretty
good the people are a bit more
conservative but that was pretty good
from a government standpoint and what i
would encourage people to think also is
when you see some of the laws
um
you know
like i'm going to give example
i was in istanbul the end of 2020 and
when i got there they said oh we're
having a weekend lockdown
we poke our heads out on saturday
everyone's walking around they're
selling hot dogs and hamburgers on the
streets uh kids are playing in the
squares and the police are watching
if that's a lockdown right i mean tell
me that's the same lockdown as what they
had in new zealand or australia or
canada it's not the same and so people
say oh walk down it's no better there
believe me all right it's a lot better
and so let america was one place even
though they had some things nobody
enforced it and then eastern europe was
pretty open i was in serbia for the
fourth quarter of 2020 um
and they closed some restaurants but i
think better uh generally that was
pretty good and so those have been the
two parts of the world from a personal
standpoint that have been good
if you think that the pandemic is over
that asia is not ready for you
um but
certainly i think for personal freedom
in general
um asia leaves you alone for the most
part um eastern europe let america be
good and then for low taxes
um
you know you're seeing more small
countries double down on tax incentives
yeah that's really interesting um what
about um you mentioned the prada shoes
which i thought was really funny um and
do you think we'll get to a point where
these um
more these countries like the us canada
and the uk will have to start to
offer better incentives because people
are leaving because we're moving into
this digital era whereby you know i
don't need to be based in the uk i don't
need to be based in the us in order to
make good money i can be based anywhere
um so do you think i don't know even in
like 10 15 years they might change their
tune slightly in order to be more
competitive
it'll be interesting to see um again i'm
a big believer in smaller countries are
best i think the biggest legacy brands
like the us the coca-colas the products
whatever it is yeah um
sure change happens in the margins but i
think that i mean most people are still
going to want to go to the us and by the
way the argument from a lot of americans
is look at everyone coming here yes by
the way i feel very badly and i think
the u.s is largely to blame yes all the
uh salvador and economic migrants who
are coming to the country because
they're pla because they're not safe
where they live and because they don't
have any money if that's not really a
barometer like we want billionaires
coming we want people building factories
coming and i'm not saying we don't want
them coming also but you know the effect
that they're coming doesn't mean that
you shouldn't leave if you're making a
million dollars a year or if you've got
a 10 million dollar portfolio your needs
are a little bit different my fear is
that yes you will see marginal changes
in places like the u.s um i think you're
going to see a big change in the u.s in
the next 15 years because all these
people are moving to florida and texas
in addition to immigration and
it's going to become impossible for
anybody who wants to keep taxes low to
win
um
but you know to me it's about culture
and
you know as they say about alcoholism uh
you gotta hit rock bottom sometimes
right if you have a family member or a
friend who's an alcoholic and they lost
their job and they want to sleep on your
couch at a certain point you got to let
them sleep on the street because maybe
it's the only thing that's going to
empower them to fix their situation
and i kind of think that you're going to
have to see that and i'm not one of
these doom and gloom people who thinks
that the dollar and the u.s are tanking
to oblivion tomorrow i think that
they've got a lot of force and they're
going to push the agenda just as you're
seeing with this global minimum tax
they want to stop competition they want
to make it difficult they want to make
it harder to get a second passport they
want to make other countries raise their
tax rates that's not the u.s deal i mean
look at andorra for example spain and
france bullied them for years and they
started taxing people so i i think that
it's going to take a long time
whether it's 10 15 years or 100 years i
don't know
um but you know i'd rather be prepared
early um
i i i think the biggest countries are
going to fight
i see that it's going to be really
interesting and we have touched on tax
havens but i would like to get a bit
more detail on that which would you say
the best tax havens right now um and how
easy is it to move there
well best is always relatively because
you've got all kinds of different people
so i think one country that um
doesn't get enough attention i think the
people there are fantastic and if you
only speak english it's a great soft
landing um is ireland and you can get
irish citizenship by descent you can get
malta citizenship in about 18 months for
a million dollars
or less
you can if you're a british citizen you
can just move there or you can get a
residence permit and they've got a great
tax incentive for foreigners it's not
talked about enough where basically you
pay for your cost of living and then any
other money you have um on top of that
is you could just stay overseas however
it's not really friendly for
cryptocurrency bitcoin what have you uh
same there it's believed and it's not
never been really formalized that they
follow kind of the uk similar law
um where it's not as crypto friendly so
if you're an entrepreneur
and you only speak english and like i
was just in ireland a little while ago
i had the most soulful conversations
there just with everyday people that i
wouldn't have in asia for example where
it's just more basic they speak english
but it's more basic
and so if you want that that's great but
if you're into bitcoin it's not going to
be as great
portugal uh is you know keeps is kept
flirting with uh you know we don't want
the bitcoin wealth um so a country like
italy could be good i mean dubai is
always good the cayman alliance are good
any of this a couple of the citizenship
by investment countries are good um
antigua saint kitts even if you're a
citizen of another eastern caribbean
country you could live in those
countries um you know southeast asian
countries like malaysia and thailand can
be good with a few restrictions and a
few caveats so i mean there's plenty of
places to go
um some countries are more bitcoin
friendly
others you know cut that out of their
tax exemption like the island um so i
mean there's there's so many places that
are coming up um and it depends on what
you want to pay i mean you can go to
uruguay for 10 years you can basically
pay nothing
you could also
live the trifecta lifestyle which for me
was i want to spend a little bit of time
in a few different places uh i'm loving
uh
you know i'm loving each place that i go
but after a while i get bored
and so if you live in colombia for
example have a home in columbia you can
get permanent residents by buying a
property you can work towards
citizenship without really having to be
there if you speak spanish
um
and their their taxation is a day's test
if it's if you're under 183 in a year
that's it
you can't do that in most countries in
europe because they're going to start
saying ah but you got a car
yeah yeah it's close enough
um colombia if you live there for four
months a year it's hardly a tax haven
but it can be a tax haven for you so
there's so many different ways you can
do it
and just finally i'd love to get your
take on bitcoin um and crypto but
specifically bitcoin just because um i
do regard it as this uh form of money
which facilitates the lifestyle which
you're obviously promoting um so what's
your take do you like bitcoin
i do we hold you know bitcoin i'm a
hodler you know i'm not i'm not someone
who's all in on anything it's my
personality i'm a very security minded
person and i think that um you know
having varying assets uh is important um
especially because you know holding
assets in some countries entitles you to
residence permits citizenships etc and i
think that more people in in bitcoin
should look at that as
um
you know oh
we we publish on on twitter for example
oh today's price of you know st lucious
citizenship is you know five bitcoin
and it's always like it'll be too soon
right and maybe your country will tax
you to oblivion or institute a wealth
tax or you know find some new way to
screw you so before it gets there so you
know better better years too early than
a day too late take some percentage and
buy an insurance policy if you you know
buy a half million dollar car you're not
going to spend 300 000 to insure it but
you would spend three thousand dollars
to insure it or even ten thousand
dollars to insure it to make sure you
don't get sued when you hit somebody so
i think figure out what you can spend on
insurance and do that and i think that
at times you know that's been my
frustration but we've worked with a lot
of people in bitcoin i'm i'm i hold a
position i i believe in it uh but i i
certainly think that um you know
diversification and everything is
important
understood um but yeah i think um
especially when it comes to you know
that trifecta lifestyle you're talking
about it's for me personally um it's a
great way to keep moving um you know you
can't exactly bring your gold with you
um as you travel around the world
and yeah for example colombia i mean
like you can't make every country work
for everything so people talk about
mexico we've talked about colombia oh
should i get a bank account in mexico no
you shouldn't i'm not saying there
aren't some strong banks there um but
i'm saying that there is you don't have
any bank secrecy not from the government
but from like people like criminals even
um and so you don't want to do that so
bank somewhere else and so yeah if you
want to bring money into colombia it's
gonna be a lot easier to use bitcoin
than like having to carry your cash or
your gold because i can tell you some of
those countries in latin america i mean
it's still like are you pablo escobar
like 100 000
uh which is why if i had to choose one
one
part of the world to skip i love mexico
city i love bogota but i would skip
latin america because i think there's
just a lot of bureaucracy in that part
of the world but
uh people are fighters there and i think
that you know as a result you can have
some decent level of freedom so yeah i
think in that regard bitcoin works very
well
yeah this is also fascinating where can
people follow you um and uh keep up to
date with all the information and value
you provide
so um we've got free resources
nomadcapitalist.com
uh we have
over 1200 blog articles we've written
over the years and and keep up to date
youtube nomad capitalist we've got over
a thousand eight hundred videos we put a
new one every day um
you can get our book on amazon nomad
capitalist we recently updated it and so
that's like 10 11 bucks and you get kind
of a nice succinct idea of stories what
you can do what you can't do just to
kind of wet your uh your beak as it were
and uh you can also go to
nomadcapless.com we work with people we
not only have no med capitalist live if
you just want to kind of come and absorb
all this in a
in a higher level setting and meet
people and learn from the playbook
that's coming up this year uh and then
we also work with uh several hundred uh
clients every year who are
um you know high level investors and
entrepreneurs who just want someone to
put all the pieces together who has the
experience in all these different
countries who has the network of lawyers
and accountants in every country and
makes sure that what you do in
portugal doesn't screw up what you're
trying to accomplish in the u.s because
i see that far too often
so from 3 to 10 bucks to five grand uh
multi-five fakers
so basically whatever you need there's a
product a service for you that fits
within your within your um bracket
andrew i wanna thank you so much it's
been such a pleasure having you on um
and it's so um important to have these
conversations i feel like i need to go
get another passport now after this so
i'm gonna go deal with that and but
thank you so much for coming on andrew
my pleasure
thank you so much and guys thank you so
much for watching please don't forget to
hit the subscribe button and the like
button so you never miss a video and we
will see you all next week bye bye the
leia hile pancho